من مقر اقامته في ولايه فلوريدا من منتجع
مارادو اعلن رئيس الامريكي السابق خوده
سباق الرئاسه لعام 2024 كانت قد بارزت
اصوات مقربه من ترامب ومن داخل الحزب
الجمهوري كانت تفضل لو اجل هذا الاعلان
الى ما بعد انتخابات الاعاده في ولايه
جورجيا لكن ترامب مضى بخطاه معلنا انه
سيترشح لرئاسه من جديد
للانتخابات الرئاسيه
سننتصدام
قوه اقتصاديه فاسده يمكن تخيلها بلدنا في
وضعه سيئه ونحن في مشكله حقيقيه وهذه ليست
مهمه مرشح تقليدي بل هي مهمه حركه عظيمه
تحمل روح امريكا وليست مهمه شخص بمفرده بل
هي عشرات ملايين الاشخاص من كل الفئات
يعملون معا
ي وما هو اشبه حتى بشرخ يتم الحديث عنه
بعد اداء مخيب للامال للحزب في الانتخابات
النصفيه وخساره مرشحين كان قد دعامهم
ترامب في هذه الانتخابات ايضا ياتي هذا
التوقيت مع بذوغ اسم او نجم راندستانس
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا كم منافس وخصم محتمل
لترامب اذا قرر دي سنه سترشح في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله ليطرح السؤال
اذا كان اعلان ترامب سيقطع الطريق على
ديسانتس واخرين من التشجع لاعلاني هم
ترشحهم للرئاسه لعام 2014